let's
collect
or let's assign to two variables the height
of the male students and the height of
Females students so you have males here.
So this we will assign.
You use a subset function?
what the subject function will do is
bringing all the data bringing all the columns.
That you have listed within a subset. So not the entire thing just
specific columns.
So this would be students. I'll show you this right now students.
So you want the subset of the students data collection?
And you want to filter?
By let's say this criteria.
and this will give you
all of the rows all
of the rows where the gender has male.
Okay, so you're filtering the data set. You
won't find any other gender here. You won't find
famous here. You can do the same thing with age height and so on. So for example, let's say
you want to divide the students by their
a major
are in Humanities are they in stem and then you
can visualize them with histograms?
And we can do the same for females.
Okay.
So now you have two.
subset of the main data collection
now, let's you and now let's plot them in histogram to see.
the distribution of heights
so the first histogram is for all of us students,
but now let's clear this and look at
a plot with two of them plotted. So
here we want.
the Heights
of the male students
and the heights of the female students.
and
we don't need to repeat ourselves.
With the scale, so this will be
color one and we will use color too for this one.
So we don't get confused when they're overlapped.
And here we want to see add.
to indicate if you don't specify the
ad then what's our studio
will do is it will generate the first histogram and then discard the
first
the preceding histogram to replace it with the other one, but we
want to include both. Let's go ahead and run this function
that gives us the height for the
male students and the second one will overlap.
Indicating the height of the female student and you can see you know.
unsurprisingly
the females tend to be on the shorter side.